welcome everybody we're starting today
with two stories that are going to upset
uh a bunch of people in my audience and
that's okay one is about jordan peterson
which we will get to the first is about
whoopi goldberg many of you wrote to me
about whoopi goldberg's statements on
the view where she is one of a number of
co-hosts about the holocaust and race
and jewish people
and as i was preparing a story about
this news broke that whoopi goldberg
indeed has now been suspended for two
weeks
by the view because of her comments
about the holocaust now
i'm just going to give you my
interpretation of what she said and i'm
going to explain to you
why what she said is so problematic and
what the main thrust of what whoopi said
on the view is that the holocaust is not
about race or was not about race and
there's really two or three different
layers of confusion here which i'm going
to try to pick apart
and there's a ton of people who still
don't understand the concept
of judaism as a race
saying well hold on but judaism is a
religion it's not really a race and the
part that makes this segment difficult
is that unfortunately i mean listen i
expect out out and out anti-semitism
from the right i get it all the time
soros funds you go back to israel a
place i've been once and have no real
connection to um you know all these
different things i i expect that from
from the right but on the left there's a
different thing that goes on and we saw
it with the women's march where for
example
the women's march from from several
years ago now
they didn't want leadership didn't want
jewish women
involved on the board because jewish
women were seen as privileged whites
rather than a historically discriminated
minority group and in built in that are
all sorts of biases and prejudices that
only reinforce anti-semitic tropes and
so the left has a problem with this too
i don't care if you don't like hearing
that i'm going to call it out on both
sides so let's just jump into the clip
and i'm going to try rather than
pre-explain let's just look at this
piece by piece okay let's take a look
well also if you're going to do this
then let's be truthful about it because
the holocaust isn't about race
no
no it's not about racism
but it's it's not about race
it's not about race
because
it's about man's inhumanity to man
that's what it's about but it's about
white supremacy but it's not it's not
about ideology
but these are two white groups of people
how do we have to blame
him as white men but you're missing the
point you're missing the point the
minute you turn it into race it goes
down this alley let's talk about it for
what it is it's how people treat each
other
it's a problem it doesn't matter if
you're black or white because black
white jews
and of course it does matter if the
people carrying out the holocaust
believe they're doing it along racial
lines because they see jews as a
different race which we will get to it's
how everybody eats each other so is it
if you're uncomfortable if you hear
about mouse
should you be worried should your child
say oh my god okay and then in another
clip again she says the holocaust is
white people doing stuff to white people
and a tennessee school pulled the
graphic novel mouse out of their lessons
on the holocaust because it contained
some nudity and some bad language
personally i'm shocked because you know
given the story of mouse i'm i'm
surprised that that's what that's what
made you uncomfortable the fact that
there was some nudity and uh
i mean it's it's about the holocaust the
killing of six million people but that
didn't that didn't bother you but the
the making i'm not sure that they don't
use the naked part as a kind of a canard
to throw you off from
the fact that they don't like history
that makes white maybe they look bad
well why this is why people do it into
wiping yeah so there is that same idea
white people doing it to white people so
here's the thing first of all uh there's
this really funny thing when it comes to
judaism where you've got
the anti-semitic right and white
nationalists who say jews are not white
jews are a different race i've had
richard spencer the white nationalist
tell me
jews are not european they're they're
not they're not what he is right jews
definitely are not white
among some on the left you have the view
that
jews are white with the white privilege
that comes with being white jews are not
minorities they're just privileged white
people and of course this is where the
concept of white passing comes up and
the truth is that
while ashkenazi jews
are absolutely white passing there's
lots of other jews uh sephardic jews
mizrahi jews who are not white passing
but that's not even really what this is
about
there's not one right answer but there
kind of is
if you take the view
that we're all one race there is no race
right like that's a view that some
people uh take now uh there's academic
circles where we're all just the human
race okay
if that's the case then this is all
meaningless right like if the view we're
taking is there's race is not a thing
ethnicity is not a thing then there's no
black people and there's no white people
and there's fine
if we accept that there are racial and
ethnic groups okay right so like if if
that's a conversa if we want to talk
about humans in that context jews are an
ethnic group
when i do my ancestry or 23 and me or
whatever it says oh your ethnicity is
100 ashkenazi jewish if i convert to
christianity religiously
i'm still 100 ashkenazi jewish and the
origin
of this confusion is that jews are an
ethno-religious group
now sometimes people like to say that's
a special pleading there's no other
ethno-religious group it's made up no
actually there's tons of ethno-religious
groups you're just not familiar with
them
the copts in egypt are an
ethno-religious group
the yazidi people of iraq are an
ethno-religious group which means what
yazidi iraqis are an ethnic group and i
hope i'm pronouncing this correctly
yazidism or yazidism is also a religion
you can quit being a religious yazidi
you would still be ethnically yazidi you
might not have heard of that and so
sometimes people say no this is
something that's only it only exists
with jews it doesn't that's not true
separately
there are also
sort of bad faith people
who pretend not to understand this who
just like to attack jews as privileged
and not worthy of our consideration
despite being at the top when you look
at religiously based hate crimes in the
united states
jews are always either at the top or
almost there in terms of being the
victims of religiously oriented hate
crimes and sometimes the perceived
whiteness
of ashkenazi jews is used as a means to
write off anti-semitism and it was very
ugly it was done in a very ugly way
with the women's march of a couple years
ago
so um that is uh
whoopi goldberg is just wrong now in
terms of her being suspended i don't i
just don't know with all of these
suspects every time we talk about
suspensions i have no idea what's
appropriate or what's not
what i want to also mention is
the suspension of whoopi goldberg
is
uh furthering
anti-semitic tropes and you can you can
probably imagine why
whoopi goldberg suspended for her
comments
about the holocaust
is proof to those
who want to talk about
jewish control of media
to say
the jews got her the jews who control
hollywood and control the view
they got whoopi goldberg and it just for
so so i'm not saying the the suspension
is or isn't appropriate but
for people who want you know when all
you have is a hammer everything looks
like a nail and so the same people who
liked many of the same people who liked
whoopi's comments are now saying her
suspension is proof
of that conspiracy of jews to control
hollywood which we've talked about many
times before so another one of these
ugly incidents and i'm curious to hear
what you think about it all right let's
go on to the next segment which is going
to anger many people in my audience i
got a ton of so let me back up last week
we looked at this interview
that jordan peterson did with joe rogan
and uh the interview was just word salad
after word salad of meaningless stuff
and predictably i got a lot of emails
from people saying david
you might not have understood what
jordan peterson was saying but it made a
lot of sense in particular his rant
about the bible
and um unfortunately
you're wrong what jordan peterson said
about about the bible did not make a lot
of sense and so we're going to go
through now we did an overview of the
interview last week now we're going to
focus in specifically on jordan
peterson's rant about the bible which
makes no sense and there's a really good
there there's this uh subreddit called
ask a historian some people would say
ask an historian that's a grammatical
preference
and i'm going to summarize some of the
comments here the reddit user who wrote
this out is kiwi hellenist who's an
expert in early greek literature so
let's go through the video
and we are now going to really focus in
on the substance
it is an unintelligible word salad and
it's also wrong on the substance so
let's just jump right in
so i just walked through the museum of
the bible in washington that was very
cool it's a very cool museum so the
structure that's with the bible yeah
that's what i figured out i mean i just
figured this out this week
so it was a cool
it was a cool thing to walk through
because
it's it's chronological they have one
floor which is the history of the bible
but it's not exactly that it's really
what it is is the history of the book
right
now in many ways the first book was the
bible okay
in many ways the first book was the
bible now what does he mean by that uh
he says he's talking about the history
of the book not the content okay so if
that's what he means the first book was
not the bible books date back to the
start of the second millennium bc the
bible dates to no earlier than the 7th
century bc or bce as is now often said
some of it came much later than that
even and the new testament is even newer
so okay first statement
the first book was not the bible it's
just it's a factually incorrect
statement
i mean literally
because
at one point there was only one book
okay
i mean literally it was the first book
because at one point there was only one
book
at one point
i guess there was only one book but it
wasn't the bible
it it was the bible was not that book
like as far as our western culture is
concerned there's one book no that's
that's not true
the hebrew bible is made up of a bunch
of different texts and they were written
over a period of time that is about 500
years
and prior to that there were many books
that were written
uh it it's what what he's saying is it's
it's factually untrue there's no i mean
i'm like over explaining it it's just
not true and for a while literally there
was only one book and that book was the
bible and then before it was the bible
it was a cl you know it was scrolls and
it was writings on papyrus and but it
was we were starting to aggregate
written texts together and it went
through all sorts of technological
transformations and then it became
books that everybody could buy the book
everybody could buy and the first one of
those was the bible and then it became
all sorts of books that everybody could
buy
but all those books in some sense
emerged out of that underlying book and
that book itself the bible isn't a book
it's a library
now
there's actually almost nothing to fact
check there
um
you know the the writings on papyrus
those were the books of the time so to
say that because it was on papyrus
they're not really books it ignores the
reality of the times
not all future books emerged from the
bible either like the odyssey was
written in the 8th century bce that
didn't emerge from the bible most of the
iliad is older than the bible that's a
book whether it was written on papyrus
or not um and then there there's this
sort of last thing he says here oh if
the bible isn't a book it's a library
the bible isn't a book it's a library
it's a collection of books okay it's not
really clear what he means by that the
bible is a book made up of different
passages written at different times and
assembled together it's a pretty vague
statement and as the culmination of
everything else that he said that's
straight up wrong it's not really worth
much one way or the other to say the
bible is a library it's not just that if
it sounds like a word salad we're not
smart enough to understand it to all the
people emailing me insisting me how
right he is
he is wrong he is wrong it doesn't make
any sense it doesn't mean everything he
says is wrong but he's completely wrong
about just about everything he said in
that clip
let me know your thoughts you can find
me on twitter deepakman
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount joinpakman.com
we depend on you here at the david
pakman show and after we were brutally
attacked by alex jones it is even more
important
uh that you grab those memberships at
joinpakman.com one of the great member
benefits is the bonus show and alex
jones yesterday
um attacking the bonus show now that
bonus show is award-winning awards we
give out sure but now it is not only
award-winning but it's also been
absolutely brutalized by alex jones you
can find out why he's so mad about the
bonus show by signing up at
joinpakman.com and you can use the
coupon code
wow22
uh to get a discount from the membership
of your choice all right uh there's
something
very interesting happening within the
republican party as we've talked about
before and that is this growing civil
war not only between
anti-trump and pro-trump republicans but
as i've said before now a couple of
times
between
formerly pro-trump republicans and
pro-trump republicans and donald trump
has now shown us
the pinnacle
of his vindictive
nature his rage at anyone who might levy
even the mildest criticism against him
he has completely turned on republican
senator lindsey graham
now let's kind of build up to it the
context here
is that donald trump has now floated
that he might pardon
january 6th rioters if he
becomes president again
uh in 2024. so here is trump saying that
for the first time at his rally in
conroe texas over the weekend here's a
reminder so many people have been asking
me about it
if i run and if i win
we will treat those people from january
6 fairly
we will treat them fairly
and if it requires pardons we will give
them pardons because they are being
treated so
unfairly so after that which is a
dangerous outrageous statement after
that republican senator lindsey graham
appeared in a tv interview lindsey
graham is a long time friend of trump's
lindsey graham is a guy who played golf
with trump regularly during the
presidency
uh
got along you know what to whatever
degree trump has friends lindsey graham
would be considered or would have been
considered a friend of donald trump and
lindsey graham says it's completely
inappropriate to do that and it seems
like it sort of might be encouraging the
exact type of violent destruction of uh
of the capital that we saw on january 6.
here is lindsay
responding to donald trump talking about
pardons pardons do you agree
yeah
no i don't want to send any signal
that it was okay to defile the capital
there are other groups with causes that
may want to go down the violent path
that these people get pardoned but isn't
that a dangerous thing to say
yeah well i think it's inappropriate i
don't want to reinforce that defiling
the capital was okay okay
so trump is asked about this during a
news max interview yesterday with rob
schmidt
and he completely turns on lindsey
graham
he calls lindsey graham a rhino meaning
a republican in name only and you really
see here
this disloyal
vindictive trump that is the guy we know
exists obviously but here it's coming up
with a guy who was in theory a friend of
donald trump's take a look
you talked about the potential if it's
appropriate of pardoning some of the
january 6th
lindsey graham said a couple days later
he thinks that's inappropriate
what do you think well lindsey graham's
wrong
i mean lindsay's a nice guy but he's a
rhino
lindsay's wrong
look
this is really the kind of bottom of the
barrel
uh
disloyal trump there's no loyalty for
trump his best friends again to the
extent he has real friends and i don't
know if he does trump's relationships
with people including his own family are
very very strange
his friends are immediately enemies if
they say just one wrong thing
graham is just the latest victim here
trump going on to talk about how many of
the rioters
are not even guilty
he says that they're patriots some of
them they're not guilty of crimes and
says lindsey graham doesn't know what
the hell he's talking about and this
this is notable for a couple of reasons
which we'll talk about in a moment
and some of these people are not guilty
many of these people are not guilty what
they've done to to
these and in many cases patriots their
soldiers their policemen what they've
done to them compared to what they've
done to the other side now by the way
the fact that sometimes they're soldiers
and policemen
that's an aggravating factor these these
are folks that we should be saying
wow
if soldiers and policemen are so deluded
that they're doing this it's not even
about criminality we should be
questioning whether they should be
soldiers and policemen for trump it's oh
but i mean they're soldiers and
policemen they just shouldn't even be
charged i guess
you know you have to have equal justice
and this is an equal
so i would absolutely be prepared and
lindsey graham doesn't know what the
hell he's talking about
if he says that because you have to have
equal justice it's very very unfair
what's happened to this group of people
now if you claim to be for law and order
and due process how can you say someone
is not guilty before their case has even
been adjudicated by the legal system
they don't care about any of their
principles how many times have i said
this now they're about law and order
when it's convenient
they're about due process
when it's
convenient prisons and jails are places
where we don't have to concern ourselves
with conditions
when it's not their people who are there
now all of a sudden trump and others are
saying the conditions in in jail that
these people are being held in are
terrible we've been talking about that
for decades we've been talking about it
for decades and then the attacks on uh
um
rather the the issue of sentences comes
up again here and trump saying uh
restating that he is up for giving
pardons some of them are being treated
very unfairly yeah i would absolutely
give them a pardon the punishment things
don't work out fairly punishments are
out of proportion to the crime out of
proportion like 20 times out of
proportion yeah i mean if they're if if
they're patriots the way donald trump
said
why on earth would they get any
punishment so this is extraordinarily
dangerous and this is a hallmark
of the
fascist dictator the dictator wannabe
the authoritarian and the autocrat right
wherever you want on that scale uh
friend of the show former guest fellow
argentinian federico finkelstein has
been tweeting a lot about this
when
law and order don't work for you
what authoritarians and fascist
dictators do is they impose their will
instead of law and order and that's what
trump is saying here we are you've got
to do everything right
you can come to the country but you got
to do it legally you ca everything just
legally the way the law says well here
we have people who are being subjected
to what the law says no no no no my will
that these are patriots is what now
matters and i will pardon them if given
the opportunity it doesn't even matter
whether he really would pardon them
uh we it's impossible to know that at
this point in time one last clip from
this interview here is the reporter i
mean this this guy should he should
really be blushing from the this
interview here's the reporter rob
schmidt
uh sort of praying at the altar of trump
and saying you know
you could be having such a great life
but instead you want to be president
again
it's it's truly unbelievable that has
got to do stuff as much as you do i mean
most people by your age just want to
relax you want to go back in what a hero
instead of just relaxing trump wants to
go back in war zone
i mean you're flirting with it right now
you're not going to announce and i
understand that but to go back into
there i think people would have to say
you're crazy very simple reason
we have a great country that's going to
hell
and it's going to hell very fast and
we're not going to have a country left
this is the same rhetoric from 2016. we
don't we're not going to have a country
great job i did more than most
presidents would do in 30 years
between the taxes and more damage right
the regulations and the business and
everything else he did the business i
mean think about how meaningless these
things are he did the taxes okay yes
there was a tax bill passed he did the
regulations of no meaning
um and he did the business
then i got we got hit with the covid
right from china and they got to pay
something for that they're going to pay
something
nobody could afford you know it's
probably 60 trillion dollars worldwide
anyway i won't subject you to more of it
but a truly delusional interview showing
us the vindictive nature of trump the
childish and jealous nature of trump
and also his complete and total
willingness to do absolutely anything
in complete abandonment of his stated
principles in this case law order and
due process
when it doesn't work out the way he
wants it to work out extremely dangerous
stuff all right one more trump thing
before we move on to other things
donald trump published a statement
yesterday in which he demands that mike
pence actually be investigated
for not stealing the election
now there's a really great article in
vanity fair from bess levin about this
where she describes uh she does she
describes trump's statement as febrile
and grammatically offensive which is
maybe the best way to describe
any trump statement that i've ever heard
and we're going to look at that
statement in a moment i encourage you to
actually read the article from by best
levin in vanity fair
but the point here is
that not only is trump saying
he wanted pence to overturn the election
and we're gonna we've learned more about
this in the last 48 hours
he actually thinks maybe there should
even be an investigation into pence so
here is the statement put out by donald
trump yesterday and again it's it reads
like one of these tweets and there's
random uh capitalization and all sorts
of different things quote so pathetic to
watch the unselect committee of
political hacks liars and traitors work
so feverishly to alter the electoral
college act so that a vice president
cannot ensure the honest result of the
election when just one year ago
they said the vice president has
absolutely no right to ensure the true
outcome or results of an election in
other words they lied
and the vice president did have this
right or more pointedly could have sent
the votes back to various legislators
for reassessment after so much fraud and
irregularities were found now that's not
true
we we looked already at the 12th
amendment and the electoral vote act i
believe it's called of
1887 i think i i
i'm now not remembering the year i think
it's 1887. we looked at this earlier uh
in the week
um it's already clear to
99.9 percent of people that mike pence
can't overturn the election or do the
things trump wanted him to do the reason
that now the language is is considering
being updated is specifically because of
bad actors like trump who are either
deliberately or out of ignorance
misunderstanding what the powers of the
pres of the vice president are in
counting electoral votes okay back to
the statement as it gets even crazier
if it were sent back to the legislators
or if nancy pelosi who is in charge of
capital security
had taken my recommendation and
substantially increased security that's
a lie by the way there would have been
no january 6th as we know it now it's
fascinating to see trump say on the one
hand the rioters are being treated
unfairly and he'll give pardons to some
of them and the sentences are unfair
while at the same time saying nancy
pelosi upping security could have
prevented it
if they didn't do anything wrong and
they're being treated unfairly and being
punished when they shouldn't be punished
why is it we needed
why would security need to stop people
from doing something that wasn't a
problem it's completely incoherent as
you can tell
um and then trump going on to say
therefore and this is like the key
whacked out line
therefore the unselect committee
should be investigating
why nancy pelosi did such a poor job of
overseeing security
and why mike pence did not send back the
votes for recertification or approval in
that it has now been shown that he
clearly had the right to do so
trump is
out of his mind
this is i mean he he this is officially
losing it
um it's also
sort of a partial walk back of his
previous statement he now
the previous statement was pence could
have overturned it
he seems to be walking it back by saying
what pence could and should have done is
send it back to the states for
recertification pence also can't do that
but it is a walk back of that original
statement which was even more unhinged
but the theme here is it's always
someone else's responsibility in someone
else's fault
pence is to blame pelosi's to blame brad
raffensberger is to blame joe biden
whoever people who allowed voting by
mail it's never
i'm to blame because i didn't get enough
votes i didn't convince enough people to
vote for me
it's that's never the explanation and i
saw a funny comment on reddit about this
sort of like faux mirage alpha male
status of donald trump and it read what
kind of person listens to him and says
yes this is the big strong man as
opposed to this is what it sounds like
when my child loses a video game and um
this this is completely over the top and
beyond the pale and this is the world of
a narcissist it's
we've spoken to psychologists and others
before
everything is someone else's fault trump
blames others for losing the election
trump blames others for not fulfilling
what he believed or asked them to do in
terms of overturning the election and at
the end of the day
this will never change when you are this
deluded and narcissistic this is how
everything is seen through this lens
we'll have some of these uh statements
and clips that we looked at in this
segment on our instagram which you can
find at david pakman show
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com
davidpakmanshow where you can get access
to behind the scenes videos the daily
bonus show the commercial free daily
show as well as special discounts on
merch including hats hoodies
mugs and t-shirts you can support the
show for as little as two dollars a
month check it out at patreon.com david
pakman show super interesting new
polling out of florida that i want to
talk about and it's looking better and
better for florida governor ron desantis
and it's looking worse and worse for the
former president donald trump when we
look at florida favorability
trump is way down and desantis is doing
very well and this is relevant for a few
different reasons which we're going to
talk about but top level when we look at
the republican field for 2024 right now
there's really two names being mentioned
it's dr donald trump and ron desantis
and of course there's all of these other
discussions about what about republicans
going back to someone like a mitt romney
who i don't think is even remotely
interested in it or whatever else those
are all perfectly reasonable discussions
or some people saying what about don jr
which i think is idiotic but plausible
given the republican electorate or
whatever else but right now we're
talking about trump desantis and that's
exactly why florida is so important so
let's take a look at the numbers a new
poll has biden losing
to desantis and trump in florida
but that's not super interesting to me
right now
uh that is that that's going to be
impacted much more by what biden does
newport this is usa today new poll says
joe biden is struggling in florida where
more than half of potential voters
disapprove of his handling of the
economy and of his job overall
suffolk university usa today network
poll of likely florida voters suggests
only 39 percent approve of joe biden's
job 53 disapprove
while president trump won florida in
2020 biden and the democrats hope to
make a big play for the nation's third
most populous state one that will have
30 electoral votes in 2024. the new poll
indicates their work is cut out for them
the most important numbers here
are and i am trying to find them
uh where exactly are they
the new poll ah desantis the first term
governor leads oh no this is the florida
so let's let's actually get to the right
data
okay
um
most republic many republicans see
desantis as a potential presidential
candidate in 24 but the new poll has him
losing a republican primary 4740 to
donald trump the poll has both trump and
desantis defeating biden or clinton in a
general election matchup in florida
desantis leads biden 52-44
trump's margin over biden is closer
47-44 so desantis is doing better than
trump against biden in the state of
florida desantis has not publicly
disclosed a run
um
and of course anything could change and
it's very very early now
it's easy to write this off and say
david
this is just a florida poll this is not
a national poll
and desantis is the governor of florida
of course he's going to do well but
that's exactly why it matters because
it's florida and because florida is
likely to be so important in upcoming
elections now there's
so much still to happen
including the 2022 midterms before we
get into any even remotely
um uh specific
conversation about 2024 but there's a
very clear trend when you look at all of
the cpac straw polls that we've recently
seen uh republican favorability polls
open-ended questions about who would you
like to see run the trends are as
follows trump favorability has been
declining
percentage of republicans who want trump
to run in 24 has been declining it's now
barely over half of republicans as we
talked about earlier this week want
trump to run in 2024
and when we talk about
who other than trump is being mentioned
the only person with any
remotely significant level of support is
ron desantis
this is another reason why i should
mention
ron desantis's re-election campaign
going on right now is so important could
ron desantis lose re-election in
november
and still run in 2024 successfully yes
he could
he could
but it is much more likely that
republican voters would support the guy
who won re-election in 22 than the guy
who lost it uh and this just has to do
with the idea of you know supporting a
loser for some bigger office when they
lost their last election has it happened
of course it has of course it has but
this is another reason why
if we could knock out desantis
it would make it an even bigger uphill
battle for him in 24 and the reason why
i say that
you might be saying well but david
what do you want trump no the the issue
is
desantis is a less incompetent but just
as dangerous version of trump in my mind
and the fact that he's less cartoonish
but has the same disastrous political
instincts
in my mind would make him more effective
at being able to destroy the country so
i see desantis as more dangerous than
trump for that reason we're going to
continue following the numbers and we're
going to continue following the
republican civil war speak by the way
actually speaking of the republican
civil war
george w bush
has maxed out his donations to two
anti-trump republicans who supported the
impeachment of donald trump i'm talking
about liz cheney yes the daughter of
bush's former vp
and alaska republican senator lisa
murkowski now let me give you the facts
first
but don't assume
what i think is important about the
story because it's not
george w bush is a good guy business
insider reporting george w bush maxes
out political donations to trump
impeachment supporters liz cheney and
lisa murkowski
okay
former president george w bush gave the
maximum allowed political contributions
to wyoming representative liz cheney and
alaska senator lisa murkowski two
republicans who supported impeaching
trump over the january sixth capital
riot new disclosures filed with the fec
said bush gave cheney 5800 on october
28th and on december 31st he gave
murkowski 2900 for her primary the fec
sets the limits on political
contributions
um
the story here is not and this is a key
thing the story here is not bush is a
great guy
we should elect people like bush we
should elect people like liz cheney and
lisa murkowski
we should rehabilitate george w bush's
image now that he's painting and doesn't
like trump
no
that is not the story and it's a very
unfortunate thing and i don't know to
what degree they're cynically doing it
and to what degree they're honestly
doing it there are some on the left who
love to take stories like this one that
i'm doing and say look at these
faux leftists who now love bush despite
him being a disastrous war criminal and
getting us into these two war
no
the story here is not what a great guy
george w bush is the story here is
the republican civil war
is maybe the best chance the left has to
help itself
because the left is increasingly unable
to help itself in any other way
that's all this is
i am not optimistic about the left in
the united states by which i mean
the most left elements of the democratic
party which at this point is the one
even possible vehicle for the left to do
anything in the u.s
i don't have any confidence that in 2022
and 2024 democrats slash leftists
are
well positioned and prepared to get
anything done and so i'm hoping
republicans will help us that's all this
is and the more republicans are divided
the more potential there is for an
opportunity to defeat them and to
prevent them from taking the house the
senate the white house over the next two
election cycles
let's not forget that every single
republican elected official
that supported impeachment
is now participating in the obstruction
of letting joe biden do anything these
are not good people and
even if they don't like trump their
obstruction of biden may well help
donald trump get reelected in three
years so
it's okay to recognize trump was more
incompetent than george w bush and still
not like george w bush
and recognize that bush donating to
these republicans might foment the
republican civil war to our advantage we
can do all of these things we can walk
and chew gum at the same time at least
some of us can there is this impulse
by some maybe
to sweep george w bush's
disastrous misdeeds under the rug
because he's painting pictures and
sharing a cough drop with michelle obama
and
donating to anti-trump republicans but
he was not a good president
his increase of the powers of the
presidency
are probably to some degree responsible
for
allowing some of donald trump's worst
abuses when he was president uh bush got
us into
some of the longest wars in american
history one based on a phony
intelligence case that he sent colin
powell to make
um he expanded torture
we're not praising bush and um that's uh
that that's the end of it and this is
how most people would behave you know
when you attack someone's family or them
the way donald trump did to george w
bush for years
it's normal that george w bush would say
i'm going to donate to the people that
are against this guy it's just totally
reasonable ted cruz did the opposite
donald trump called ted cruz's wife ugly
and then ted cruz fell in line and said
trump's amazing he's fantastic he's
great we love him we love trump
most people wouldn't do that most people
would do what george w bush is doing it
doesn't make him a hero and it doesn't
make him someone we align with
politically period full stop end of
story
let's follow
this republican civil war and see to
what degree it can be useful to the left
to try to get some wins or at least
prevent some losses in the next two
election cycles
follow us on social media interact with
the david pakman show community see
exclusive content see when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
big show announcements we post daily
find us on reddit twitter instagram
facebook discord and tick tock
all right a couple of newsworthy items
that i want to touch on um the trump uh
records that have been sent to the riot
committee the january 6th uh riot
investigative committee of the house of
representatives
some of those records were torn up and
taped back together and this is an mo
that we're already familiar with with
the trump organization and
administration the washington post
reporting
some records sent to the january 6
committee were torn up taped back
together mirroring a trump habit
when the national archives and records
administration handed over a trove of
documents to the house select committee
investigating the january 6th
insurrection some of the trump white
house records had been ripped up and
then taped back together according to
three people familiar with the records
former president trump was known inside
the white house for his unusual and
politically unlawful habit of tearing
presidential records into shreds and
tossing them on the floor
creating a headache for records
management analysts who meticul
meticulously used scotch tape to piece
together fragments of paper that were
sometimes as small as confetti as
politico reported in 2018 but despite
the presidential records act which
requires the preservation of memos
letters notes emails faxes and other
written communications related to a
president's official duties the former
president's infrangible shredding
practices apparently continued well into
the latter stages of his presidency the
national archives on monday took the
unusual step of confirming the habit
saying in a statement that records
turned over from the trump white house
quote included paper records that have
been had been torn up by former
president trump the statement comes in
response to a question from the
washington post about whether some
january 6 related records had been
ripped up and taped back together
this is about 700 pages of documents
transmitted to the january 6th committee
uh last months
now
this
you might remember
that
not only ripping up documents is
something donald trump would frequently
do
there are uh claims that trump ate
documents
um
this is crazy but we reported on it back
in 2018 and it's all part of the same
thing newsweek report trump ate
sensitive document
after cohen meeting former white house
claims uh former white house aide
omarosa manigault newman has said she
walked in on president donald trump
eating paper after a meeting with lawyer
michael cohen
this is so insane in what she believed
was an effort to destroy sensitive
information this was from her book
unhinged an insider account of the trump
white house newman makes a series of
disturbing and amusing allegations about
the president's conduct
newman recalls i saw him put a note in
his mouth
since trump was ever the germaphobe i
was shocked
he appeared to be chewing and swallowing
the paper it must have been something
very very uh sensitive so listen whether
trump ate notes or not
um there's no doubt at all like even if
omarosa is lying there's no doubt
whatsoever that the ripping up of the
notes was a common thing we reported at
the time that there was like a team of a
couple people
that were their job was to pick up
confetti sized pieces of paper and tape
them back together to remain in
compliance with presidential records and
the like and of course this is not the
behavior
of an innocent person and when it comes
to records about what happened on in the
lead up to in the immediate aftermath of
the january 6th trump riots
why would he be ripping those up and uh
of course
innocent until proven guilty all of that
stuff but this show is not a court of
law it's a court of opinion my opinion
and it is not in my opinion the behavior
of an innocent person last thought on
this
i don't have to remind you
that just about every promise that was
made
um by donald trump leading up to his
administration
was a lie or it didn't come true
one of those claims was we will be the
most transparent administration ever
remember that trump had one press
secretary who held zero or one briefings
in her entire tenure it was a relatively
short tenure i admit
um and also remember that trump ran on
hillary can't be trusted and is not
transparent hillary's hiding emails
hillary deleted email hillary used
private email hillary can't be trusted
with sensitive information hillary can't
be trusted with classified information
and it all happened during the trump
administration trump spilling secrets
that were received from ally israel to a
russian spy recruiter in the oval office
remember that one
ivanka jared the whole team
using private email throughout their
work for donald trump in the
administration and on and on and on
so there's five or six stories here
and shockingly the one of trump eating
notes is not even the craziest or more
dangerous one
okay
last thing on again every day we are
learning more about the insanity that
took place in the aftermath of the
november election and the in the lead-up
to the january 6 riots by now
you have no doubt heard if you've been
watching my show listening to the
podcast over the last year
all of the different ways in which they
were trying to get a hold of the fact
that joe biden won the election and that
they wanted to try to overturn it we've
talked about
uh 63 court filings all of which were
found to be without merit some to be
some were found where there was no
standing and many of them found to be
without merit we've learned about oh
mike pence is going to flip the election
somehow
either by something he does himself or
by sending it back to the states or you
know whatever the case may be
we also heard about declaring a national
emergency slash martial law and there
was this idea of seizing the voting
machines now what you do with the voting
machines once you seize them to flip
results
we can speculate we don't exactly know
but we now have reason to believe that
donald trump himself
who's shocked by this donald trump
himself was much more involved than
previously known in the plan to seize
those voting machines the new york times
breaking the story this week
trump had role
in weighing proposals to seize voting
machines
new accounts show that the former
president was more directly involved
than previously known in plans developed
by outside advisors to use national
security agencies to seek evidence of
fraud
six weeks after election day with his
hold on power slipping trump directed
giuliani to make a remarkable call
trump wanted him to ask dhs
if it could legally take control of
voting machines in key swing states
three people familiar with the matter
said remember that giuliani did so
calling the department's acting deputy
secretary who said he lacked the
authority to audit or impound the
machines
trump pressed giuliani to make the
inquiry after rejecting a separate
effort by his outside advisors to have
the pentagon take control of the
machines and the outreach to the
department of homeland security came not
long after trump in an oval office
meeting with then attorney general
william barr
raised the possibility of whether the
justice department could seize the
machines a previously undisclosed
suggestion
that mr barr immediately shot down
the new accounts show that trump was
more directly involved than previously
known in exploring these proposals to
seize voting machines as he grasped
unsuccessfully for evidence of fraud
that could help him reverse the 2020
election
right now
everyone's attention
is focused on the coup
and on election fraud and that makes
sense but look at how much we've learned
just about that and then think imagine
for a moment
how much other
um
crazy stuff was going on that we still
don't know anything about that will
likely be uncovered about the last four
years
it will probably take
conservatively another four years
to figure all of that out and it could
even take closer to eight to ten years
for it all to shake out in terms of its
repercussions
um it's very clear that they did attempt
a coup but they seemed not that
competent at it
they seemed as competent at
doing the coup
as they were at governing when donald
trump was president and it failed and it
became a sideshow but we can't write it
off and not worry
because as i said earlier desantis is a
more competent trump and that makes him
more dangerous and these same techniques
now with the experience of 2020 knowing
where the hold-ups were knowing where it
ended up stalling
with a more competent person at the helm
could be a very dangerous proposition
and we've heard from
retired military generals who say if
trump had had the generals on his side
could have been a very different outcome
we've heard about
if there had been more willingness in
the house and particularly the senate
to
attempt to reject or challenge some of
the results in a more serious way in
multiple states
it could have been a different outcome
now one more thought about this uh trump
role
in trying to seize voting machines
remember when william barr quit
seemingly out of the blue as attorney
general on december 23rd december 23rd
was the date
of uh william barr's resignation letter
did william barr
see the writing on the wall about what
was coming on january 6th maybe not
specifically but knowing this is
potentially bad and i don't want to be
associated with it and that's why he
abruptly quit because if you consider
the timing the meetings where the idea
of a national emergency was floated
the meetings where the question about
can we seize the voting machines all of
this stuff happened between the november
election and december 23rd when william
barr quit
and it seems
plausible at least that barr knew or
suspected that something insane was
coming and decided to get the hell out
of there before it did doesn't make barr
any better of an attorney general
it's just bar acting out of
self-interest the timing makes sense at
some point maybe we'll know for sure
we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192davidp
uh i am really really really regretting
something i did on the show
two weeks ago now
someone said david if you had to leave
the country where would you go i have no
plan to leave the country i don't think
it's going to be necessary to leave the
country but i answered the question
anyway and i said well i could go back
to argentina anytime because i was born
there so i could i can go anytime
as a jewish individual i could go to
israel at any time
um i'm working on getting european
citizenship through my grandfather who
fled poland before will but i'm not
planning to do any okay
the number of messages i have received
now from people saying david i'm
canceling my membership because i don't
want to be with someone who's going to
abandon us if the going gets stuff all
these different things i regret even
talking about it and now this is sort of
the height of it
this caller said david
you planning to leave
makes you seem
like the unpatriotic jew who will take
his capital and leave with no loyalty
we've gotten to the anti-semitic tropes
part
of the leaving the country timeline take
a listen to this
hey
dave my name is jeff i'm calling about
your recent segments reference you
leaving the united states if things go
authoritarian
yeah that raises a couple of concerns i
think that we're born out in alex
jones's response to those videos
the first concern is is that it
reinforces the trope the jews aren't
really patriotic or good citizens in
here you know you're saying if things
get bad enough you'll leave
a second uh concern is it promotes a
trope that
you know jews are a global set who will
pick up their capital and split look for
better markets the first sort of trouble
i'm saying this is a guy who by right
may go to israel or may go to spain
but i won't go to either one of those
places except and only if i'm a tourist
if things get bad here it's only because
we let them get back
guys
i'm not leaving
in a true dystopia the likes of which i
was imagining when i answered the
question we would all be looking to
leave there wouldn't be any more tourism
it would be an emergency we would all be
looking for safe haven me being jewish
wouldn't change that this was a question
asked by the audience if you were to
leave because things got so bad
where would you go and it's true if i
left i'm not going to go to thailand or
norway where i both don't speak the
language and have no way to actually go
to legally if i left i would be more
likely to go to argentina because i was
born there or to israel for legal
reasons but i'm not planning on leaving
and it was clearly a very big mistake to
even entertain the question
what a disaster
on today's bonus show we will talk about
a massive winter storm coming that will
stretch 2 000 miles
it is going to hit areas that don't
typically have winter storms
and are much less prepared
and have disastrous infrastructure are
we looking at another potential
uh
episode
of what happened in texas with
electricity in a bunch of states because
this storm is so widespread and if so
what are republicans going to say about
infrastructure hope it doesn't happen
we'll talk about it on today's bonus
show we will also talk about the big
headline among many on the right that
for the first time ever america's
national debt has surpassed 30 trillion
dollars what does it actually mean
without hyperbole we will talk about it
and lastly
their uh jury deliberations have started
in the roy moore defamation case you
might have we talked about this case a
long time ago
you might have forgotten about it
uh jury deliberations have started and
we're going to talk about what's at
stake there all of those stories and
more i am told
uh on today's bonus show
we will be uh i'm i'm told there's
something going on for my birthday on
today's bonus show i don't know what it
is i'm as curious as you are
join it uh joinpakman.com get instant
access and we will see you on the bonus
show or otherwise tomorrow